Hey David, you talk a lot about believing
women, but what would you do if you were falsely
accused of sexual assault?
Let's discuss it.
This actually came up when I was on, remember
that show I went on in LA, the Jesse Lee Peterson
show.
We were talking about the Brett Kavanaugh
hearings and he asked me in some way, would
you want to be accused of a sexual assault
you didn't commit?
And I said, that's not really a question,
Jesse.
No one, I don't, I don't want anyone accused
of a crime that they didn't commit.
Of course.
Uh, and in fact, there was a movement to do
this at a time when I was covering the Kavanaugh
hearings.
I started hearing from people who said, David,
we're going to go to your local papers.
We're going to claim that you sexually assaulted
someone.
And my understanding is that some of those
allegations were actually made and they went
nowhere because they obviously were not credible.
But let's answer the question as asked.
False rape or sexual assault allegations are
very rare.
But when they happen, they should be punished.
And I've said that for a very long time, but
let's play it out.
What would I do if I were accused of sexual
assault or rape?
And I had not done anything wrong.
First and foremost, I would say nothing and
I would immediately call a lawyer.
Now I know that that already puts me in a
position of privilege, right?
Not everybody can afford a lawyer.
Um, well if the police want to talk to you,
uh, if you are being compelled to talk to
them, then you can request a lawyer.
And if you are not being compelled to talk
to them, then I simply would not talk to them.
But I would immediately reach out to a lawyer.
I would not attempt to contact the accuser.
I would not attempt to contact the accuser's
family.
I would immediately think to myself, who might
be able to either provide an alibi or be a
witness in some way.
I would immediately try to put in writing
whatever interactions I may have had in my
life with the accuser, if there are any, if
it's genuinely someone I don't even know,
I would of course not have any interactions
to write down.
But if there's someone that is known to me,
I would immediately put in writing interactions.
I would check social media records.
I would check email, whatever and and really
categorize for myself what the interactions
have been if any.
Now I get it.
False allegations.
Anytime that you have a system that allows
people to um, uh, make a complaint that they
have been victimized by, by someone else,
there will be some percentage of either straight
up false allegations or mistaken identity
problems were an accuser believes it was this
person when in reality it was that person.
What I, I really want to state here is I'm
glad to answer the question about what I would
do.
These are not common situations.
I don't want to give them more importance
than they deserve.
I believe it is a far bigger problem for those
who are victimized by sexual assault or rape
to never have justice done to the perpetrator.
That is a far bigger problem mathematically
than false rape allegations.
Most importantly, the most important thing
that I do in order to avoid allegations of
any kind is I don't sexually harass or assault
people, which in 99.99, whatever percent of
the cases is actually your best insurance.
If I'm missing something, if the actions I
would take are not the right ones, let me
know what I'm missing.
We have a great bonus show coming up for you
today.
Of course, the Friday bonus show hosted by
producer Pat, and he will be telling you about
next week's plan with Thanksgiving upcoming
and much, much more.
So make sure you are a member@joinpacman.com
or a patron at patrion.com/david Pakman show.
Pat will speak to you.
Then I'll be back on Monday, the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.